good evening everybody
in uh councillor proctor's absence i
will be
cheering the the meeting this evening
alex could we have the
apologies that we've had so far please
we've had apologies from councillor
proctor councillor dillon councillor new
mr goodman and mr brown
all right
so we still are one or two missing but
we have enough to continue so that's
right thank you for that
it's the last meeting i was not at the
meeting last time um
i'm assuming you've all had an
opportunity to
look at the minutes
can i have someone who was here to
propose that we accept those as a true
record
i can do that
i also did send alex noted three or four
typos
right are they biggies
um can i have a second for that please
thank you
sorry i've just received further
apologies from council new grosh
by your email
just in time
love it
okay so we have a proposal we have a
second
are we all
happy to accept the minutes
thank you
right moving on to item three the
implementation of the
counselor develop or the members
development plan
for this we have a presentation
victoria you're
doing the presentation can i hand over
to you now it's all yours thank you
that's better so my name is victoria
tolbert and um i've taken over as
organizational development and learning
officer at trafford taking over from
neil meanham
in october this year so far
so i'm not completely new to trafford i
was working on workforce reform in the
locality area previous to this so i've
sort of moved over to a fixed term
contract so
um so there's still a wee bit of
learning going on at the moment so i'll
try and answer your questions as best as
i can or if not i can take away an
action and feed it back to you but it's
lovely to meet you all and there's some
familiar faces that i already know here
so
starting on the first page this is
around your core courses or what we
would say in the business your mandatory
courses the figures in the green and
area the 57 and the
262s
this relates to how many people have
been enrolled onto the course
so it's not it's doesn't relate to how
many uh members are within the system
our system picks up enrollments um
when we run a report on there
so this report was done from may the
first 21 um to date when i ran the
report last week i think it was around
the report
so some of the members will still have
certificates that are already valid
because they'll still be within that
12-month
period of time before their other
certificate runs out
so what we can see is from our gdpr
report there that 57 councillors were
enrolled on the report and 32 have
completed it we've got other language in
there in process and not started
not started means they've clicked on the
course but haven't started it
or in progress they've
they've started some of the course but
not got
right to the end and taken the quiz at
the end which will validate that they've
passed the course
so the completion rate for this is 32
which looks around um 56
and then safeguarding adults we've got
62 people enrolled with 38 completed so
that's 61 completion rate
and then safeguarding for children drops
off and i'm not too sure what the reason
for this is because we're looking at
62 people enrolled but only for
completing it which is about six percent
so i don't know if people are getting
confused seeing the word safeguarding
from their reminder emails and deleting
them without realizing this two separate
courses there
but these are the three courses um
that are on offer from trafford so these
are the
the core ones to be completed
okay
so these are additional courses on offer
that we have within our learning system
from the lga
so these are an additional resources for
members and again we've got the
completion rate across the top there and
of course not started and in progress as
well
so it's quite a low rate for these lga
courses but again they are additional
and we know that e-learning um doesn't
always fit everybody's learning style
they are convenient because you can do
them at any time of the day at your
leisure or go back to them and have a
look at them and we know that different
kind of types of learning appeals to
different people in different ways
so moving over um we do have our
internal provision and we offer bespoke
trafford-based sessions for members so
the ones that we've run recently of
course was the induction program which i
know many of you attended with um a
variety of different workshops earlier
in the year
we've also held an inclusive leader
course and this is in line with our
trafford equality strategy and this has
been rolled out to all um
managers within trafford at the moment
we held this on a saturday morning
virtually and five members attended
there was really good feedback um from
the session they found it really
insightful to the role and there's a
particular activity that we do in there
around reflecting on your own diversity
window and how this relates to your
go-to people around you and how you get
that feedback
we also did values based recruitment as
well
so this
session covers the role of members on
the interview panel and trafford's
direction in being a values-led
organization with the epic values
so it was really a really good session
it was
attended by nine members and it was an
hour-long session
they found it insightful to their role
in the power and the power of the right
question and the quality of the
questions asked are incredibly important
in that recruitment process
and then finally we do offer our
external um attendance to members as
well we do have a budget for that i mean
luckily really we're not seeing those
face-to-face big conferences at the
moment that can be quite expensive a lot
of things are offered online at the
moment at a significantly cheaper rate
so this is a flavor of what people have
been on already this year so we've had
quite a
wide variety of different courses but
also as well there's been a bit of a
focus around personal safety um with
with the recent sad events that have
happened there as well so we still do
have the budget the money is still
available um to be used and approved for
that external attendance
so really the next steps for the new
year is to think about those kind of key
topics that we're looking at that we can
do in the house bespoke for members and
also kind of highlight those key
learning opportunities externally as
well
we're still supporting the member
development steering group and we had a
meeting last week with those
and carrying on the minutes from
those meetings as well those key actions
so we're utilizing different channels to
encourage compliance with manda with
mandated learning those core modules
that we're looking at there with the um
e-learning and that includes you know
um attending meetings using the data
promoting it your newsletter our
internet pages for you and just keep
you know raising that awareness to make
sure that people are completing their
relearning and also keeping the internet
um pages up to date especially around
the learning oops page that we've got on
there
and using that as a great learning and
communication tool as well
i know within the paper it includes
around your continual professional
development as well and that's something
we can look at in the new year to make
it quite an easy exercise for people to
do so it's not a laborious task but it's
a simple tool to track your own learning
and make sure that you're on top of
everything that you need to do
and also thinking about your own
development as well
okay would anybody like to ask any
questions
um
these the figures on the um that
safeguarding the children were very low
weren't they i mean i just think there's
been a lot in the press about
local authorities and children at the
moment it
might work well it's trying to make an
effort to push that as you say people
might have been misreading their emails
not realizing it was a different course
definitely definitely something that
we're definitely going to look at and
push to make sure that we can get that
figure
up um
i don't know
in terms of for committee members who
sit on the children panels that are
relevant to children i don't know what
additional training they may get on top
of that
so i'm i'm sure they're um
you know working towards that but we'll
definitely have a look into it and find
out
what is happening with those figures
there this one
would there have been any
selectivity
about the
safeguarding children's circulation
i asked the question because i'm looking
desperately here and i'm finding a lot
of stuff that i'm getting about
safeguarding adults level one
but i'm not finding anything on
safeguarding children
is that particularly for e-learning or
this is the
i regularly get a reminder that i
haven't done this course
and i regularly get the one for
safeguarding adults i've just found
that i'm not finding any for
safeguarding children i will double
check that in the system and i can use
that yeah
[Music]
yeah
i will double check and see what it's
sending out
i'm glad it's not just me
we've got quite a few
courses titled safeguarding so it
it can get a little bit confusing with
people enrolled on them the children's
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah it should be in your library
there's a course library on there that
you should be able to
access it with
[Music]
[Music]
let me quickly look for you
i don't know if they'll i'll have to
quickly just log into our
system
yeah yeah
okay
if memory searches i think they're the
same that um stuff have to do it's about
half an hour a piece
yeah
i've got a feeling the adult
safeguarding is about an hour
from what i remember from memory
thanks jay
um
yeah first of all well done i mean i
think the membership development has
been excellent
and um there's some really great courses
on that i've noticed the lga courses
which have scared me off a bit
do tend to be in the region for about
four hours are they
i take it
you can start them and
yeah yeah yeah you can because they're
broken down into modules so yeah you can
go back to it the planning one for
instance is four hours long so i'd
imagine that might be a reason that
some people haven't yeah engage with
them
and i bet it's absolutely riveting
[Music]
thank you
thank you and yeah i'll get back to you
with those with that information okay so
thank you very much
and
yeah and happy christmas as well to
everybody thanks bye
[Music]
uh sorry council can just remind
everyone to use the microphones on
speaking just because um we're
webcasting and the webcast only picks up
from the microphones
so i'll switch the microphone on now
okay moving on to item three
now we've done item three moving on to
item four
the uh
councillor's code of conduct now we had
a discussion about this before uh before
the meeting so let me ask you to
talk us through this please
good evening everybody um i've got the
majority of the reports tonight so i
apologize in advance for having to
listen to me all evening um okay so the
first of my reports tonight is on the
code of conduct
and
it's fair to say that we've had a series
of reports on the code of conduct
previously come through to the committee
and certainly at the
last
committee meeting i sat and we went
through some of the highlights in terms
of the differences between model code of
conduct from the lga and our current
code of conduct
and at that point
i explained that we should perhaps do
some consultation with various interest
passes and that was approved and
following that meeting that's what we've
done we've gone away and we've we've
consulted with
various interested in parties
we've had some responses and we've we've
reviewed those responses and the
suggestions and we've collated them and
contained them within the report as you
can see tonight and so the report really
is a summary i'm not going to go over
the previous detail i think we've done
that in some detail
what the report is proposing is that we
now have a code of conduct which we can
take forward and adopt for trafford and
so we therefore ask the committee for
your approval
um subject to that proven
we would then ask you uh for a
recommendation
of um the code of conduct through to
executive um we have um chosen to take
it to the executive and then on to the
council meeting and for the purposes of
giving it some real uh
time really we would like to bring it to
as many people's attention as possible i
think it is important that people are
aware of the code of conduct and the
changes and so that's the proposed route
to
approval
[Music]
thank you dominique uh i was surprised
not by the content because
it's the way i hope we all behave
but the fact that i have never in
something like 17 years
read the code of conduct
which we have now
um what i'd like to do first of all is
just open up the any discussion that we
want to have about the content of this
report before we go to the
recommendation that is to
present it to the executive
at a suitable
opportunity in the near future has
anyone got any comments they want to
make please
thanks chair i just quickly wanted to
ask dominique i take it as a greater
manchester council so we're also looking
at the lga model code of conduct and and
possibly taking it on too
the answer is i can't tell you with any
certainty
what the position is nationally we do
know that there's a high
majority of councils that have adopted
the lda code some has drafted some with
local amendments in terms of gm
there was a
desire to come up with a gm position so
one that could be adopted across the
whole the gm
that um was meant to be led by chief
legal officers there was a um
an initial meeting which i attended um
and there were some
difference in opinions really around
whether they felt the code was ready
there was an almost concern around
infancy and uh some of those concerns
were highlighted in the consultation
document that i that i sent out but
essentially it was a real case of we're
not really sure how to take this forward
there was also a concern that
in terms of the
model code as it was presented it deals
with declaration of interest slightly
differently and there was a feeling that
actually the code went beyond what you'd
be required to do in accordance with
legislation
um and that created a i wouldn't say a
concern but a nervousness and so i think
what they were thinking was well there's
even got to be a change in legislation
to to balance that out or actually
changing the code
that coupled with the idea of or the
feeling that this is a very new code and
it's in its infancy and it's already had
minor remainders throughout the
development process
led to different gm authorities taking
different approach so
i know at least three of them have
adopted two as is and one has made local
arrangements um the rest
are essentially either not publicized
what they've done with it yet and just
pause on it or they're not just not
ready to look at their own codes yet so
there's a real
difference um in terms of those concerns
obviously those are something that we
have taken on board here and actually
looked at do we share those concerns and
we don't we don't share those concerns
at all and we feel that
i feel particularly that this code is a
much more robust code for trafford um it
is very in keeping with the principles
that we already have
it has been consulted on nationally
and in terms of is there a difference
between the legislation and the
requirements there and what the code
does my view is no there isn't um and so
there's certainly nothing that would
prevent us from moving forward of course
if at some point in time gm authorities
do get to position
where they want to review it
and reach that stage where they come
with a gm model then we are at liberty
to consider that at that point but we
don't know when that will be and so to
to do something more now for ourselves i
think is more proactive and the best
option for us
would i be right in
my thoughts on this subject
are that if we go ahead on our own with
something that's very close to the lga
model
whatever happens
we're
we're well positioned
to be able to adapt should we be forced
into changing things
yeah that's correct so um our previous
worth noting as well um that our
previous code our current code is was
also based on the national lga model um
and we led on the
adoption of that across gm
at that time and so by adopting what we
have here um yes we are anticipating
that the model code will evolve over
time
that's natural and it should do um but i
don't think that's going to leave us
with a drastically different code of
conduct as we go on and certainly what
we would be suggesting for a gm
level is that they stick close
the whole point of this is that it's a
nationally recognized standard and
that's what the objective is and so to
create the idea of creating a code that
would be different from that
it doesn't really sit well so
we did discuss earlier that one thing
that isn't actually stated in here is
don't post to social media after 9 30 at
night or a third glass of wine
because that whole area seriously of the
social media is new and that's exactly
the sort of situation that
will perhaps potentially
require us to make adjustments but as
things sound at the moment
this document works for me um i hope
that
we can all accept that
and that
i'm
looking for a contribution yes yes
sorry um i was looking at the actual
draft of the code as proposed i mean i
noticed of just a couple of typos but
then there was another pointer um on
paragraph seven which is bottom of page
five
there's a missing apostrophe
trafford council's
requirements
this in the
this is the proposed
code of conduct the actual document that
you're talking about
could i invite you to i'll send those to
send them through yeah
bit more substantial point um i know at
the last meeting i think we
the in the model code it said protecting
your reputation that was the word that
was used and then the consultation
people said well preserving sounds
better
i was sort of
thinking about it over the weekend
and even preserving
i don't quite capture don't think
captures what you mean it's really
upholding
and i just wonder whether that is a
better term for that um
uh it's paragraph nine
preserving your reputation and the
reputation of the council i wonder
whether upholding is actually what
you're talking about
because later on in the document i think
the word maintaining is used
that's the word i was thinking of
substituting
not because i've seen it before but
during this
few moments of consultation uh that
maintaining that
it makes the assumption that you're
already always standard
that the preserving the defensive nature
of the word preserving um
is
yeah it's perhaps worthwhile
yeah i mean obviously it was something
that was fed back to us um through the
consultation process um i'm happy to
take on board any suggestions if that's
the agreed position we can amend the
code
with that word in so i'm more than happy
to take that forward
i apologize um
can i just refer you to um
section 5.1
where there's a sort of um list of the
steps we're going to take over the next
three months or so
and then specifically about the training
program
and
following the last uh the last
presentation we had obviously uh
uh it was done by e-learning it was done
uh over the internet i think that's by
far the um the best way to do this
particular sort of training so can i ask
that that is um considered at least
please chairman
thank you
no not at all again um you know this is
much about getting your feedback and to
make sure that this worked for us so i'm
have to take that comment on board and
if that's agreed then we'll make those
uh amendments
i must admit that
until i read this next section i not
even thought about how important it was
uh the general dispensations
uh
under which we operate now again um
we discussed this before the meeting
can i ask you to pick that one up as
well dynamic
yeah absolutely so
it is very much linked to the previous
report in respect of
our current code
contains a list of a general
dispensations within the code itself
and considering the model code this time
around
that doesn't provide for that so what we
are proposing to do is within the model
code what we have said is there is a
there's a reference to um
dispensations and what the code says is
that our dispensations will publicize it
will go on our website
now um the reason why we are suggesting
that approach is that obviously it does
give some um some transparency around
what the general dispensations are but
it also allows us to have a flexible
approach to those dispensations to
review them and keep our eye on whether
there needs to be any changes so um
what we need to do now is consider what
general dispensations we
need to approve as a committee so
in terms of
dispensations obviously the monitoring
officer can consider granting a
dispensation where certain criteria are
made
and previously i think for the last
eight years
um we have gone for this general
dispensation and the whole purpose
really is to capture
those declaration of interests which
would regularize at every single
committee meeting and would perhaps or
disrupt usual course of business
ordinarily um
the monitoring officer would consider
those declaration of interest and uh
granted dispensation
in individual cases this is to to to to
get away from that this is to agree a
list of general dispensations where
those um
interest would not need to be
declared in in such a way so
it's
worth noting that the dispensations as
listed in the report
are the same list of dispensations that
have been in our code of conduct in our
constitution for the last eight years
however we have reviewed it again and if
you go back and look over the years the
list gets shorter and the reason for
that is really they're not relevant and
so what we're left with tonight in
tonight's report is those dispensations
that we believe are relevant to the
ordinary course of business today and so
the report really asks
for you to consider
the dispensations as they are listed and
to approve them
if approved those dispensations will
stand for four years and that's the
approach that we've taken previously
four year period of course there's
nothing to stop us from reviewing that
within the four year period and we can
of course then update that list and
republish it
um so we do need to take this now um we
need to take this decision now because
at this point in time
the previous list of dispensation four
year period has now expired which is why
we're we're dealing with it tonight
thank you
i think we
that the explanation you've all heard
now
is very comprehensive
the idea of a four-year
cycle means that we don't have to worry
about it every single year
but
it was stressed to me and you heard it
just now
that should a weakness arise
or perceived a weakness arise we are
able to renew this
before the four year
expiry
and the other thing that attracted me to
that four-year period is it takes us
comfortably over
the uh what's likely to be a major
change
of caused by the all-out elections
in 2023
so we will have a set of dispensations
and a set of standards in place that
will carry us over that point then
should the makeup of this committee then
decide they want to review it there's
nothing to stop them
so
we are able to actually adopt these
dispensations as a committee
we don't have to take this to the
executive
right
so for the first time this evening a
vote of real weight
can i have a
proposal
that we that the general dispensations
are set out in the report are taken
forward
uh as the dispensations for the next
four years
thank you
and a second
thank you
all those in favor
aye
any against
carried unanimously thank you and
thank you for your efforts and putting
that together
okay moving on now to
the item on the publication of members
addresses
we are in an environment where
this has become probably more sensitive
than has been in the past
i have an opinion
i have an opinion about this which i
will share with you now that we should
have
the
facility should we desire it
to
have our
addresses published in council
documentation
i have to say that that's because i
don't feel threatened
at all
i'm an aging white male
and over my life i've been deemed to be
a risk by everybody from aoka
in cyprus in the 60s through to
the provisional ira and barda meinhof in
the 70s
um
so i'm probably a little more casual
than some people and what i'd like to do
is actually hear your opinions i think
we should have put those opinions on
record
about uh
how we feel about the publication
of idea of
information that identifies the place
where we live
within the borough so anybody like to
start that
um well
quite a different opinion i'm i would
very much like my address not to be
accessible in two clicks as i googled
myself earlier and found the address
you know within a matter of seconds um
i just think you know in the
in the light of
events in recent years albeit for
members of parliament but we're not a
million miles away
um i would much prefer our address to be
stated as the town hall you know we're
very accessible in other ways and i
don't believe that there is a real need
for our addresses to be published you
know i i can't think of a single reason
why that might be um appropriate so and
having um canvassed
my
labor colleagues who were elected with
me in may this year they were very much
of the same opinion i have to say almost
stopped me standing it made me think
twice
um
about standing having two young
daughters at home and you know
it's
certainly a safety concern
for me so yeah
that would very much be my opinion
a very valid position no
no question any other comments i would
like to make
yeah i think um up until a couple of
years ago john i would have agreed with
your view but
as a female an elderly female who now
lives alone and
i feel very safe where i live but my son
keeps lecturing me about security
um
i've never been threatened personally
but
another member of my family has um and i
think at one point he did remove my
address from the register of interest
so i'm a bit either way i know um
correct me if i'm right um dominique
we now have the option of not putting
our address on the ballot paper um
we can put traffic to town hall can't we
now but i know as shown it says two
clicks
but
one part of me kind of thinks why would
anybody want to know exactly where you
live and go to the trouble of making
those two clicks
when they we are contactable by email by
telephone
um
that people can write to the town hall
so i'm a bit sort of on the fence with
this one but my attitude has changed um
more recently i think because of recent
events
[Music]
okay i've got a little admission to make
i didn't notice
that we had an option
of not
publishing our
addresses on the ballot paper this time
i just automatically assumed it
one of the things that we've been
discussing and is in the report is that
this won't be compulsory
because there will be people with strong
feelings either way
and i personally will continue if i'm
allowed to
to publish my address the only problem
i've faced not even a problem a bit of
light entertainment having a couple of
drops turn up on my doorstep
with issues and complaints
on a saturday afternoon um which
adds a little bit of color
but i can see that some people might
find that threatening
as
opposed to the
the way that i
perhaps
would deal with that sort of thing so
totally accept i think we all we should
all accept the the argument that says
you should have the option
and uh
i think that's the level of uh you
mentioned that you'd canvassed your uh
your recent intake
that perhaps we take this forward as a
consultation with all members
uh to to make sure that we've got a
agreement
and an understanding so i certainly
didn't have understanding i really did
believe that you had
that you needed to publish it
so that your
voters
knew where you learned where you lived
um
and knew how involved you were
but perhaps that's a very naive view
i'll uh i'm prepared to accept that
so
should we agree then that we take
this report
again to the executive
and ask them to carry out or to organize
a structured consultation amongst
members
and should we
expand that beyond
just members
because at this point it only affects
people who are members
but do we need to do anything more to
cement this issue of the names of
addresses on ballot papers
okay
yes thank you chairman um
i think i'm in agreement we should in
fact be able to with with hold our
addresses and some 20 years ago
uh following my appearance on the
licensing panel i wasn't applying for a
license i was hearing someone else's
application for a license
um the same evening a device was thrown
at my house which blew a hole in the
drive luckily it didn't do any further
damage
but the two things were kind of the
police pretty sure that two things were
connected but it couldn't be proven
um so i would
i would be very much in favor of not
actually publishing that information
at least making it too easy for people
to find that information and i think at
the moment it's also on the uh
our declarations of interest i think the
address appears there as well
thank you chairman
you see that takes us beyond
the theory that's set out in this in
this report and what bothers me now
is that when we have the consultation
we'll discover that other people some of
the more long-standing members perhaps
have suffered
experienced that sort of thing
but thank you
it's not an objection at all i'm your
independent person so i can't sort of
get involved as a as a counselor in this
but i raised this a couple of years ago
to say personally i come from a
background
where we protected a lot of people in
terms of their security and safety
and
i argued at the time that there should
be a means whereby the register was held
within a secure area within the council
and that people should be able to get
access with the right
requirements for it
but just to have it available i think
the laws that i've sort of looked at
through the reports that have been put
forward
are really this case of the the law not
catching up with technology quick enough
technology has got to that stage where
you say you're two clicks away when
maybe you were of that uh era that you
thought yeah i'm happy to accept all
this
the strange people that are out there
that do want to actually know these
things
maybe for
reasonable reasons but for some it will
be unreasonable reasons and it is far
too easy for those people to get to them
my fear is if you take well i think you
do need to take it to the the council
but
but the same time
it's looking at the legislation and
saying the legislation is saying
you've got to prove this fear and
harassment
that to me is wrong i think it should be
the other way around
it should be that you should just be
able to say as you say i don't want it
there i know where it is to be kept and
if somebody wants to contact the council
it's available but i think just to sort
of say we accept that
you um
you've got to prove
this fear harassment or otherwise i
think you might need to from my opinion
go out in the limb and say no we're just
going to do it we're just going to stop
it
and
who is it that's going to complain about
it if there is
both a democratic and legal way to be
able to get to this information
if you're doing everything to protect
your councillors
and that's my view is that it's it's not
about the law behind it's about actually
protection of people before the
potential of that event happens
and you've obviously found that it can
happen
and i think a couple of years ago there
was some other instances where there was
people turning up at doors
so i can't vote on this and wouldn't
wish to but at the same time i hope my
opinion is valuable to say i think you
ought to really go out and limb if you
have to to say these are protected
i think it's a little more than just
valuable i think it's absolutely
critical that we get to that we get an
answer on this now
are we able to create a situation which
says
we can
deny the problem we can avoid the
publication of names and addresses
without going through any procedure
for proving the
need to do it
okay so
this paper is obviously before us
because luckily you know i think in
trafford we don't have um generally
concerns around safety amongst members
um it's it's more of a discussion prompt
around how can we be preventative maybe
because we have to acknowledge as it has
been alluded to you know
world's changing social media etc and so
we're working a different way now so
this was to open up a discussion around
that and we know that there are some
members that are concerned
and um there is certainly a gap
in terms of legislation and recent
changes there was changes that
does allow a member to um or a candidate
to um
to
refrain from having their addresses on
the ballot paper now that was
determined
specifically for the safety of members
but it fell short of doing anything else
and that's why we've got this gray area
and um of course you know if you find
yourself in a situation where you do not
want your address publishing
again going back to that dispensation
conversation but the there's a very high
bar as we've just heard and so it's
about you demonstrating that
there is a real risk of harm and
violence and that's quite high bar
um
and so it's whether we need to do
something
around that
how do we how do we deal with this in a
preventative way or do we need to do
that in a preventive way and what does
that mean so in terms of what we could
do going forward
the options are set out in the paper
let's do nothing
there's a middle ground where we could
say um
you know we could look at
um
whether we go down a dispensation route
and make that clearer to members
or do we go another step where
where we would basically take a blanket
exemption approach to it and the way
that we could do that is by by
formulating a policy and having that
formally approved as a council policy
which basically says that
no addresses will be published
now
some councils have done that and it sits
within a policy within their um usual
framework of documents and that would be
the the most transparent way to do that
and so
um
this paper really is about
i don't think we understand the current
feeling generally and i think we're
going to have opposing views but it's
about where do we where do we land where
do we want to land now and do we want to
review that going forward and i think
it's about opening up that discussion at
this stage around consultation
so we can format some
further solutions i mean we've we've
talked about three they could possibly
be more um
you know so we can explore that in any
way that you would like us to
but i think it is something that is
worth considering
more from a preventative point of view
than an actual there's a need to do this
now so perhaps think of that um why
so i think we still come back to
consulting with other members to to get
a consensus
on this
um
interesting i didn't expect this to
uh
create quite so much discussion thank
you for that all of you who've
contributed
anyone else want to make any comments
okay
sorry
let's make a final comment i mean um i'm
all in favor of consultation but i don't
think i agree with my colleague over
there as an independent member um i
wouldn't like this to be kicked into the
long grass
i think it is i think it is a matter of
great urgency
and i wonder could we as a committee
take a steer and by recommending
three point one as sorry through is it
three point three
um
as our feeling and if everyone comes up
with strong objections then
there you have the debate but i think we
ought to take a steer on this actually
as a standards committee
i would agree with you on that um
[Music]
what i'll suggest is that i will speak
with
council proctor as chair
and we'll find a way of taking it
forward
but absolutely
we must avoid taking it into a long rest
we need this sorted
well ideally before the
the next election comes around
which gives us
all of four months well three in a bit
um
so i take that one on board completely
thank you
okay thank you for your time everyone we
have one final item
the monitoring officers report a verbal
report
do you still want to talk to us
well
to be honest i don't have anything by
way of an update um i did obviously have
a chat with jane um before
the meeting and she had nothing to raise
either by way of concern report or
update either so i will stop talking and
i'm sure you're glad of a break
so thank you for your time
time of death 1920.
you